it's like a dream imagine in the empty
desert you come upon a huge wheel ringed
in skeletons and someone invites you to
come pull a series of heavy ropes at its
base so you walk to one side where a
team is waiting and you all throw your
backs into it
and you pull in turn and eventually the
wheel roars to life lights begin to
flicker and the audience cheers and
you've just activated Peter Hudson's
Karen one of the world's largest
zoetrope
this is the farthest thing from
marketable art it's huge it's dangerous
it takes a dozen people to run and it
doesn't go with the sofa it's
beautifully crafted and completely
useless and it's wonderful you're
unlikely to see works like Karen in the
art world headlines these days the
buying and selling of artwork often gets
more attention than the works themselves
in the last year
jean-michel basquiat sold for a hundred
and ten million dollars the highest
price ever achieved for the work of an
American artist in the painting by
Leonardo da Vinci sold for 450 million
setting a new auction record still these
are big important artists but still when
you look at these works and you look at
the headlines you have to ask yourself
do I care about these because they moved
me or do I care about them because
they're expensive and I think they're
supposed to in our contemporary world it
can be hard to separate those two things
but what if we tried what if we
redefined art's value not by its price
tag but by the emotional connection it
creates between the artist and the
audience or the benefit it gives our
society or the fulfillment it gives the
artists themselves
this is Nevada's black
desert about as far as you can get from
the galleries of New York and London and
Hong Kong and here for just about 30
years at Burning Man a movement has been
forming that does exactly that since
it's early anarchist years Burning Man
has grown up today it's more of an
experiment and collective dreaming it's
a year-round community and every August
for a single week 70,000 people power
down their technology and pilgrimage out
into the desert to build an
anti-consumerist society outside the
bounds of their everyday lives
the conditions are brutal strangers will
hug you and every year you will swear it
was better the last but it's still
ridiculous and freeing and alive and the
art is one thing that thrives here so
this is me on the desert playa last year
with my brother obviously hard at work
I've been studying the art of Burning
Man for several years for an exhibition
i curated at the Smithsonian's Renwick
gallery and what fascinates me the most
isn't the quality of the work here which
is actually rather high it's why people
come out here into the desert again and
again to get their hands dirty and make
in our increasingly digital age because
it seems like this gets to something
that's essentially human really the
entire encampment of Burning Man could
be thought of as one giant interactive
art installation driven by the
participation of everyone in it one
thing that sets this work aside from the
commercial art world is that anyone who
makes work can show it these days around
300 art installations and countless
artistic gestures go to the playa
none of them are sold there at the end
of the week if the works aren't burned
artists have to cart them back out and
store them it's a tremendous labor of
love though there's certainly a Burning
Man aesthetic pioneered by artists like
Kate Rodin bush and Michael Christian
much of the distinctive character of the
work here comes from the desert itself
for a work to succeed it has to be
portable enough to make the journey
rugged enough to withstand the wind and
weather and participants stimulating in
daylight and darkness and engaging
without interpretation encounters with
monumental and intimate works here feel
surreal scale has a tendency to fool the
eyes what looked enormous in an artist
studio could get lost on playa but there
are virtually no spatial limits so
artists can dream as big as they can
build some pieces Bowl you over by their
grace and others by the sheer audacity
it took to bring them here burning man's
irreverent humor comes out in pieces
like Rebecca Waits Church trap a tiny
country chapel set precariously on
wooden beam like a mousetrap that lured
participants in to find religion it was
built and burned in 2013 while other
works like Christopher shark's firmament
aim for the sublime here under a canopy
of dancing lights set to classical music
participants could escape the thumping
rave beats and chaos all around at night
the city swarms with mutant vehicles the
only cars allowed to roam the playa and
if necessity is the mother of invention
here absurdity is its father
they zigzag from artwork to artwork like
some bizarre random public
transportation system pulsing with light
and sound when artists stopped worrying
about critics and collectors and start
making work for themselves these are the
kinds of marvelous toys they create and
what's amazing is that by and large when
people first come to Burning Man they
don't know how to make this stuff it's
the active collaborative maker community
there that makes this possible
collectives like 5 ton crane come
together to share skills and take on
complex projects a single artist would
never even attempt from a gothic rocket
ship that appears ready to take off at
any moment to a fairy tale
inside a giant boot complete with
shelves full artist made books a black
bird pie in the oven and a climb above
Bienstock skilled or unskilled all are
welcome in fact part of the charm and
the innovation of the work here is that
so many makers aren't artists at all but
scientists or engineers or welders or
garbage collectors and their works cross
disciplinary boundaries from a grove of
origami mushrooms that developed out of
the design for a yurt to a tree that
responds to the voices and biorhythms of
all those around it through a hundred
and seventy-five thousand LEDs embedded
in its leaves in museums a typical
visitor spends less than 30 seconds with
a work of art and I often watch people
wander from label to label searching for
information as though the entire story
of a work of art could be contained in
that 180 word text but in the desert
there are no gatekeepers and no placards
explaining the art just natural
curiosity you see a work on the horizon
and you ride towards it when you arrive
you walk all around it you touch it you
test it is it sturdy enough to climb on
will I be impaled by it art becomes a
place for extended interaction and
although the display might be
short-lived the experience
stays with you nowhere is that truer at
Burning Man than at the temple in 2000
David best and Jack Haye built the first
temple and after a member of their team
was killed tragically in an accident
shortly before the event the building
became a makeshift memorial by itself
it's a magnificent piece of architecture
but the structure is only a shell until
it disappears under a thick blanket of
messages I miss you please forgive me
even a broken crayons till colors
intimate Testaments to the most
universal of human experiences the
experience of loss
the collective emotion in this place is
overpowering and indescribable before
it's set afire on the last night of the
event every year something compels
people from all different walks of life
from all over the world to go out into
the desert and make art when there is no
money in it the works not always refined
it's not always viable it's not even
always good but it's authentic and
optimistic in a way we rarely see
anywhere else in these cynical times
it's comforting to know that we're still
capable of great feats of imagination
and that when we search for Connection
we come together and build cathedrals in
the dust forget the price tags forget
the big names
what is art for in our contemporary
world is not this thank you
[Applause]